We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host, and suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials no one else planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time, making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacard app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. We're just right on top of each other today. I know. That's what she said. That's what she said. I was just about to say that. Oh, boy. Oh, Lordy. What will this be? It's going to be so fun. If you guys just want just like about 50 minutes of joy and fun times, stick with us. We have a great episode today. I'm super excited about it.
Okay, first of all, I need to say this. Everyone listening, you know we record a few weeks in advance, right? Yeah. Yeah. Well, one reason I'm so excited about today is the week we're recording this is actually Jenna's birthday week. It's my birthday week. It's your birthday. So hello from early March. And by the time you hear this, it's going to be a few weeks after. But, you know, we have to celebrate the week of your birthday. Well, Angela, you do for sure because you love a birthday.
And I love this about you. You told me you wanted to do like a fun birthday episode today. I love it. I came in and there's a plant and a balloon from Sam and a book. And Angela, there's a gift bag here. and some homemade granola from Josh and a cake. And a cake. And some surprises you don't even know about.
What? Uh-huh. Oh, my goodness. That are going to be sprinkled through. You guys, I love a birthday. When we started our company, I said, everyone gets a dessert on your birthday and some kind of fun to do. These are our rules.
We go to the bathroom when we need to go and we have a fun birthday. I love that when, you know, companies, when they're forming, they do encourage you to put together a mission statement, sort of a vision of your company. Yeah. And I love that when we did that, that two of our things were about going to the bathroom and celebrating birthdays. Yes. And I said we'll always have snacks. I think it really captures the two of us.
I said drawstring pants. This is like truly like lawyers. We had to open an LLC and all those things. Right, right. What's your mission statement for your company? This is what we provided. They're like, but like, what about like the business? Yeah, do you need insurance?
No, no, no, we're going to celebrate birthdays. Yes. Okay. Well, in honor of your birthday week, let's get to this episode that is called Jenna's birthday and call sheet questions. Woohoo. But you told me something I find intriguing and I can't wait to hear about it. You said that you have a birthday theme for yourself.
You told me this the other day. We were talking on the phone. And here's the thing I know about you. You love a theme. I love to name things. I don't know if I got this from Kendra or what, but naming things. It points me in a direction. But I have a theme for my 52nd year, and here's what it is. Books and Fabulous Women. This year, I want to read books and be around fabulous women. And I will tell you, it is already
happening. For my actual birthday, I'm having a little tea party with some book-loving women. and Angela, you're going to be there. I know. I'm very excited. I got a flowery dress. Oh. I just thought that's what you wear to a tea party. I'm literally throwing myself my own Finer Things Club for my birthday.
But I will also say this has already been one of my most memorable birthday weeks because it started with getting to present at the actor awards. I mean. Craziness. And talk about being on theme, getting to be with fabulous women. first off, just being with you and Ellie and Mindy, but also, lady, we got to meet so many women that I admire when we were at the awards. But I feel like I'm getting ahead of myself. Should we talk about how that all came about? Because it was crazy. It was a whirlwind for y'all listening. Tuesday morning, the week of the awards, I got a text at 8.15 in the morning.
I'm like in my bathroom. I do like my little rose spray on my face in the morning and my eyedrops. what's happening, right? And my phone pings, and it's Mindy, and we're in a group text, and she's like, hey, ladies, I heard we might be presenting the award for Best Comedy Ensemble at the Actors Award this Sunday. Yeah. Excuse me what? What? What? Huh? Yeah. And by 9 a.m., it was locked. We were presenting. They had reached out to all the ladies of the office, the main cast. Kate Flannery was touring with Jane Lynch, so she was unable to go. Yeah. Phyllis was in St. Louis, and we were was just like, ladies, thanks for thinking of me, but I cannot get this together in time. Phyllis, I hear you, we were here in town and barely pulled it off.
So it ended up being me and you and Ellie and Mindy and this scramble that started. We had five days to be a word show ready. It's so crazy to me that we were just talking to Chelsea Fry about this, about how, you know, when this whole thing started in our lives, we'd get invited to things. We'd be like, how do you get an outfit? How do you pull it off? Lady, 20 years later, I am no better at it. We were just still as, like, perplexed.
We don't go to fancy shit anymore. No, we don't. We have been invited to things, you know, when we're like, eh. But, like, an award show. Presenting? Presenting with Mindy and Ellie. That's 100% a yes. But we had nothing.
We don't have people. We don't have, like, I didn't know where I was getting anything. I was completely unprepared for also the glow-up, like, This is the thing that cracks me up. We get this information on Tuesday, three days before the award show, as we're scrambling to get outfits, Jenna sends me a picture and goes, I got those crest white strips. I was like, surely just two days of a 14-day crest white strip pack will totally transform my smile. I know.
I was like, oh, good idea. But then, Angela, you were like, I have a weird tan line on my arms from tennis. You guys, I have a full t-shirt tan. I have like a scoop neck around my neck, and then I have short sleeves, like a full t-shirt tan. But you're like, I'm going to sit outside for 30 minutes. In a tank top. Yeah, and I'm thinking, lady, 30 minutes is not going to fix this problem. And I'm sure you were like, good luck with your crest white strips.
I know. Which, by the way, I just want to say, really work if you do them for the 14 days. Like, they do work. You just need the whole thing. I don't want to disparage. I actually love them. I do too. I thought your teeth looked fine. Thank you. I don't know how we did it, but we pulled it all together. It definitely took a lot of effort on multiple people's parts, and I think we should thank a few people. We should because in addition
to pulling it off, we had this hilarious text thread, Yumi, Ellie, and Mindy, like the night before we started sending each other pictures of what we were wearing, and we were weirdly magically coordinated. It was so cool. It was crazy. Also, like black and plum was where we landed. I tried on three dresses. Only one really fit me. So that's the one I went with. You guys all saw it. That's what Ellie said too. Yeah. And I loved it. Yeah. Loved it. I loved it. Your jumpsuit was so cool. Well, let me tell you what I did, lady. I reached out to my friend Lindsay Price, who I did splitting up together with. I have reached out to her before. She has dressed me. before from her own closet. She is my personal stylist. This is who I go to. It is such a cute thing about
y'all's friendship because she's so fashionable. And every friend group needs one gal that knows fashion. This is your person. She's the Carrie Bradshaw of my friend group. She has the amazing closet of clothes. And I wrote to her because I knew she had this suit that I had worn when we did our book tour. I know. And I thought, can I? I borrow the suit. I know it fits. It's fabulous. She was like, I'll send the suit, but I have another idea. And she sent me this sequined jumpsuit. And she said, this is what I think you should wear. It was so cool. It was like beaded. It was strapless. It had this velvet like sash. It was very chic. I loved it. She added the sash. She did. Yeah. She was like sending you this sash because I think
it'll elevate the outfit. She thought of that. The sash made it. I love the sash. I would have never I never thought of this, Ash. Same. I know. But then one problem, I couldn't sit in it. I couldn't sit down, really. I had to sit at an angle. It was an interesting car ride to the event.
You had to lean back. Yes. And so after we presented, I changed into the suit. I did a wardrobe change. I've never done that before. You felt very badass. I did. I was like, where's Jenna?
Ellie's like, she's in that tent. Like, they had a little area. Backstage. Where you could change. Yes. Yeah. My dress, I want to shout out my friend Kimmy, who's a stylist, and she's such a busy gal. She does so many high-end things.
And I just reached out to her, and I told her, like, on Tuesday at 9.30 a.m. Kimmy, I'm going to be presenting. She's like, oh, my God. And she brought over three dresses for me. And the one I wore was a loner. I borrowed it just for that night, which is also, like, stressful a little bit, because I'm like, can't get anything on this. You know.
This is going back to someone. It's got to look good. Yeah. But thank you to the ladies that came together. I thought we all looked fantastic. Gosh, I felt really like glamorous, you know? I did too. It was fun.
And the whole night felt special. From the minute we got there, we skipped the red carpet guys. We skipped it. Me and Jenna and Ellie were like not doing it. It gives me anxiety. We got to go into the artist entrance. Yes. But that was really cool.
It was cool. And then the minute you go backstage, there's the green room. This was like the glitziest green room. Hanging out with the other presenters, I felt like I was in the cool club. I'm never normally a part of. The first people that I saw when I walked in the green room was the entire cast of one battle. Minus Leo. Minus Leo. Of one battle after another. He's filming in Rome or something. I looked it up here. I was like, why isn't he? He didn't say he wouldn't be there. But I got to meet Tiana Taylor. Yes. We walked right. pastor, she looked amazing. Also, she is so warm and kind and lovely and brought her daughter.
And I had sort of a list in my head of people that I hoped I could say to them, I loved your work this year. And she was one of them. And I did get to say that. And that was really cool. Yeah. She was lovely, just inside and out. But we also got to meet Odessa Desion from Marty Supreme. She was another one on my list. And do you know what I said to her, by the way? What? Because I've worked with her mom, Pamela Adlon, was her mom. And so I was like, oh my gosh, we tell your mom I said hi. And then I was like, what am I saying? I just turned into like that, like, dorky aunt. So she was on my list as well. And another person on my list was Wunmi Mosaku from Sinners. She was lovely. And seven months pregnant.
Seven months pregnant. She and I chatted about being really pregnant at an award show. I was super pregnant at the Screen Actors Guild Awards. That's what they were called back when we were nominated as a show. And she and I talked about just like navigating that night in like a big, long, flowy dress and just like, give me home. Well, she is amazing and sinners. If you guys haven't seen it. Yeah. She has this one scene in particular that just blew me away.
Talk about someone who can command a moment. Yes. Yeah. Yes. And lady, you chatted with Gwyneth Paltrow. I look over who's so tall. She's very tall. Well, next to me, too.
Big difference. Hey. Well, I mean, it was a striking difference. She's really so tall. And I had on three-inch heels, so... I'm right in the middle of you guys. Well, here's the thing. When we walked out on stage,
they had an order. I walked out first, and then Jenna and then Ellie and then Mindy, right? We walked out in this order. So I'm the first one walking out there by myself, and I was like, ah, the person I lock eyes with, I'm standing right in front of is Gwyneth Paltrow.
And I look right at her and I make this kind of smile like, hey, and she smiled right back. And then I sort of left my body because then I looked at the whole room and I was like, oh my gosh, what are we doing? And I got a little nervous for a second. But after the word show was over, we were walking like towards the exit together. And I turned to her and I said, Gwyneth, I'm Angela Kinsey. And she was like, hi. And I said, I just wanted to say thank you.
I locked eyes on you right as I walked on stage. and I was a little nervous and I kind of gave you this dorky smile and you smiled right back and just kind of settled my nerves. And she was like, oh my goodness, you guys were fantastic. And she was really nice. Well, you know who I locked eyes with as I walked out on stage right in front of me. Connor's story. I know.
Sitting right there next to Sarah Paulson. And I locked eyes with him and I went, ah. I was being a fan of his work. But then later, like you, crazy. This is a crazy moment for me. We ended up sharing a chair. You did because we, you know how, like in the commercial breaks, people get up and chat. Yeah. So we got up and we were chatting. And then when the show starts back, you quickly have to sit down wherever you are. It's like musical chairs. It is. And I sat in Sarah Polson's chair, Sarah, sorry, I took your chair and Sarah crouched
on the ground next to me. I was like, Sarah, I'm so sorry. And you quickly sat down and you and Connor sat. set. We sat on the same chair. Same chair. Oh, but you guys, it was just, it was amazing. I'm sorry if we're going on and on, but we haven't been to one of these in a real long time. And it was just so fun. I finally got to meet Quinta Brunson, which was another highlight. And we got to hang out with Paul Muskell and Jesse Buckley. Oh, my God. Backstage. Jesse Buckley offered to take our picture. I was like, what is happening? Yes, we were like, can we get a picture with you? And at the party afterwards, we saw Rose Byrne, who I love, and Catherine Hahn, who I've been friends with for so long. And Rea Seahorn was at our table with her son. Her son. Mm-hmm. She was wonderful. And Sterling K. Brown.
Who called me Ange. I know. And I was like, Sterling, my family calls me Ange. How do you know people call me Ange? And he said, well, my sister's name Angela and I call her Ange. Well, there you go. And I was like, Sterling, you can call me Ange forever. We've dropped so many names.
We have. Sorry. But all of these people were wonderful. So if you want to know what they're like, the answer is wonderful. And maybe most wonderful of all, not that it's a contest, sweet darling Oliver Hudson with the crazy tattoo. We ran into him. He's so fun. And here's the thing about Oliver.
You know him way better than I do. Obviously, y'all did show together. But when you meet him, he's one of those people where you feel like you've known him your whole life. Yeah. He's so. No, he's just so easy to be around. And he told me, this is what's crazy. Guess what? I said that this night was full of fabulous women. Guess what? Books made their way in
because Oliver Hudson is a voracious reader. Oh yeah. We actually got, I won't say reprimanded, is the right word, but there was a security man that said, you need to leave now. Because everyone had to exit into the party that you spill into this party next door. And you two were talking about the books you were reading, and you were so invested in this conversation, I was like, y'all need to walk. Talk. Yeah. And then the next day, just texting about books. So Oliver's going to be my book friend this year, I think. He also said he's going to come on the podcast. We think we need to play two truths and a lie with him. I think we do too. All right. Congratulations on your birthday theme of fabulous women and books. Yes. We have some fun surprises plan for you. I think we should take a quick break, have some birthday cake.
And when we come back, we're going to do the call sheet questions in honor of your birthday. Great. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve. Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence.
Just take care of your own well-being for a chance. BetterHelp makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and it works, with an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, help.com slash office ladies. Have you ever felt like you are living just a B or B plus life? It's so dangerous to live that. More dangerous than a B minus or a C plus life? Because when you're living a B or B plus life, you don't change it. You think it's good enough.
Is it? I'm Susie Welch. I host a podcast called Becoming You. People think, okay, an A plus life is not available to me, but there is a way. We are all in the process of becoming ourselves. Listen to becoming you wherever you get your podcasts. Right, we are back. And before we kick off the call sheet questions,
I have two fun things we're going to do in honor of your birthday. Okay. The first thing is, I'm going to share with you some trivia from March of 1974. The year you were born, Ms. Fisher. The number one grossing movie, the month of March in 1974, was the Great Gatsby. starring Robert Redford and Mia Farrow. Oh, wow. You know I've never seen it.
Really? Yeah, I saw the Leo DiCaprio one. You should see the original since it was the big hit the month you were born. Done. I'm going to do it this weekend. The top television shows The Month You Were Born in 1974 were all in the family and Sanford and Son. Wow. Mm-hmm.
Those are two really cool shows. The number one song The Month You Were Born was Seasons in the Sun by Terry Jacks. Well, the music was moody. The film was kind of romantic and over the top. And the television was very cutting edge. Yes. Hmm.
I like it. I like the artistry of my birth year. You were meant to be an artist, is what it tells me. All right. And now are you ready for a little birthday surprise? We've had birthday trivia. Now it's birthday surprise. Okay.
I reached out to Matt and Sam, and I said, Jenna loves books. This is part of her birthday year theme. I want us each to read a little passage from a book that we love. That means something to us. I love this. And then, lady, you are going to be getting the books we talked about. This is so exciting.
Yes. All right, Sam, why don't you go first? Sure. Okay, so this is a poem, actually. It's only six paragraphs long, but I've heard the end of it my entire life. but I just recently heard the entire thing. It's by Dylan Thomas. It's called Do Not Go Gentle Into That Good Night.
It says, Do not go gentle into that good night. Old age should burn and rave at close of day. Rage, rage against the dying of the light. The wise men at the end know dark is right, because their words had forked no lightning, they do not go gentle into that good night. Good men, the last wave by, crying how bright their failed deeds have danced in a green bay, rage against the dying of the light. Wild men who caught and sang in the sun in flight,
we learned too late they grieved on its way. Do not go gentle into that good night. Grave men near death who see with blinding light, blind eyes could blaze like meteors and gay. Rage against the dying of the light. And you, my father, there on the sad height, curse, bless me now with your fierce tears, I pray. Do not go gentle into that good night.
Rage against the dying of the light. So that was written by Dylan Thomas, and I want to say, 1940, but it reminded me of you. I am naturally very complacent. It's a Wisconsin upbringing. I'm very docile. It very easily will fall in line with things. But you strike me as somebody who knows exactly what they want at a light, is very particular and isn't afraid to change the things in their life to get what they want. I've always really admired that about you. I think in this 52 years you've been alive, I think you are successfully raging against the dying light. Sam, first of all, I love
that you picked poetry because it is a sect of literature that I'm less familiar with. Yeah, me too. And I would love to know more. So I'm excited that poetry is coming my way. You're getting the book, The Poems of Dylan Thomas. And I love that poem. And everything you just said, that just means so much to me. Oh, great. Happy birthday. I love you. Thank you. I love you. That was so beautiful, Sam. Damn you. but Matt, you have a book. Now, this is a book Jenna already has. So Jenna, you're going to be getting two books. Okay.
Because this one, we believe you have. But Matt, I'll let you take it from there. Well, yeah, when I first came on the show, we were reading the same book, a marriage at sea. And I really thought that was so cool, you, me, and Barack Obama, because it was on his book list for the year. Oh.
But I just thought that was awesome. And I was like, oh, cool, we have a shared love of this book. We're reading at the same time. So I picked a quote from that. And this is from A Marriage at Sea by Sophie Elmhurst, which was a great book about a couple surviving at sea together. And the quote is, I believe in all human beings, there is a desire to love and be loved to experience the full fierceness of human emotion and to make it a measure of the success of one's life. And I really love that to quote rent to measure your life and love. So, yeah, I hope it's a wonderful year for you with lots of love.
Thank you, Matt. And I love that you threw a little theater into there as well. I love it. Yeah, that's a beautiful passage and that book is really incredible. And now I know if I ever meet Barack Obama, I can bring up this book. You can talk books. Yeah. Thank you. Okay, Angela, your turn. Okay, my turn. So I brought a book in because, you know, I love show and tell. But this book is really special to me because it was one of my dad's favorite books. And when he passed away, my mom gave me a bunch of his favorite books. My dad was always reading a book. He had a lot of long hours that he traveled back and forth to the rig, and he would read when he traveled. So this is one of his favorite books, and there's a connection to my hometown as well. This is my dad's copy of Lonesome Dove by Larry McMurtry, and it won the Pulitzer.
So this was really amazing for me to go back. Written in here, it says given to Billy Kinsey for his 50th birthday in Archer City, Texas on July 26, 1985. And I don't think you have this book. I don't. Okay. So it's this epic Western novel written by Larry McMurtry, who's from Archer City, from my hometown. And we all grew up knowing his family. My mom is very good friends with his sister. I went to school with his nephew. My dad went to school with Larry for a while. So this is very rooted in our hometown. But more than that, The book is just a really beautiful story about love and loss and friendship and the end of the Old West. It's got a huge large cast of characters.
And it really centers around Augustus McCray and Woodrow Call, who are these Texas Rangers, and they're on this very dangerous cattle drive from Texas to Montana. But there's so much love and life that happens to them and the people around them along the way. And there was two things that I like. And I find that I like the things Augustus says. He's such a bigger than life personality. But one of the things he says in the book that I liked is, if you want one thing too much, it's likely to be a disappointment.
The healthy way is to learn to like the everyday things like soft beds and buttermilk and feisty gentlemen. And then the other one, a lot of people, like when you look up like quotes that people love from this book, this is one that a lot of people say. but I loved the idea of just being comfortable with everyday things, and that is you to me. You really enjoy just your cup of coffee in the morning makes you so happy. It does. Sitting in your cozy nook and reading a book or going for a walk with Lee. These are the things that just fill your bucket, right?
And afternoon with your kids, just hanging out in the backyard with your dog, Maggie, and just those little moments are you. And this one is one other quote. share, it ain't dying, I'm talking about, it's living. I doubt it matters where you die, but it matters where you live. And I see you embrace that all the time, especially the journey you've been on the last few years. You know, you want to make now matter. Oh, wow. Yeah. So you will be getting a copy of Lonesome Dove. I'm very excited, you know, I particularly love stories, like, on a prairie. I love prairie life stories. I didn't know that. Well, they have a very kind of survivalist
aspect to them. Yes. Because like so much of the day is just about gathering food. Survival. Yes. You know, and cooking the food and trading the food. So I love prairie stories. So I think I will enjoy. This sounds like there's some ranching in there. I'm here for it. There's a lot of ranching. And there's a lot of just life and really interesting characters. If someone drinks coffee like out of a tin cup over a fire, I'm going to love it. You're in. And lady, my last gift for you is to just honor your heart for service. You volunteer.
You donate a lot of your time and resources to helping the unhoused people in your area. This is true. You never talk about it. You don't brag about it. but it is a wonderful thing that I know about you. So in honor of your birthday lady, I made a donation to the Library Foundation of Los Angeles. Thank you.
You're welcome. I just thought, you know, I want to support this part of you that I love. And the Library Foundation of Los Angeles provides critical support to the Los Angeles Public Libraries. That results in free programs, resources, and services available to millions of adults, children, and youth. and by supporting the Library Foundation of Los Angeles,
you help transform lives because your generosity is ensuring that the public library thrives for generations to come. Well, that means so much to me. Thank you, guys. Oh, my gosh. You know what has been so special about this is how very seen and known I feel right now. I'm so glad. I'm so glad.
Thank you. I feel like as we age birthdays, they just mean different things, you know? And we're not in our, let's go out and party birthday phase. No. We're like, and let's just be around the people that we love and know us. Yeah. Oh, thank you. Thank you, guys.
Happy birthday. Thank you. Happy birthday. All right. Now it's time for the call sheet questions with Jenna. You all listening know the call sheet questions. We've talked about the many times. They were the questions on the back of our call sheets while we were working on the set of the office.
Kind of a fun way to get to know you. And we're going to ask them to Jenna today. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? Well, I think I've talked about both of these on the podcast before. So my very first time being paid to act was murder mystery dinner theater in St. Louis, Missouri. And it was in the summer after I graduated from college. And I got paid $50 a show. And I did this two-person partially improvised.
murder mystery dinner theater, you know, in the haunted bed and breakfast restaurant where I saw the ghost and all that. But that was truly the very first time someone paid me to perform. Did you have to play multiple characters or were you just one? I played one character and then the man that I worked with, he played multiple characters. So what was interesting about that was that every time he left the room to change clothes, I had to keep it going. You had to vamp. Yeah, I had to vamp with all. all the people in the room. Yeah, so I played the lady of the house. It was my dinner party that I was
throwing. And then he played Jeeves, the butler. He also played the inspector who came to say that a murder had happened. He also played like my dopey brother who maybe was the murderer, but the murderer was always someone in the room because everybody got apart. And so he must have had different accents and things. Different accents, different costumes. He was very tired at the end of the night. I bet. I find it so amazing that, one, your first paid acting job was theater, which is your true love. Yes. And two, it was a dinner party. Yes. And it was in St. Louis. It was in my hometown, which is really cool to me that I didn't even have to leave in order to get paid to do what I love. And then when I came to Los Angeles, my very first acting jobs were all
background work. And I told the story of having to ride the Jurassic Park ride for 11 hours to shoot that commercial. And I did background work on the movie Pleasantville with Toby McGuire and Reese Witherspoon. That was like a two-week job. That's an amazing gig. Yeah. And you got to wear like the period kind of piece outfit. I did. That was a crazy one because there's a scene in the movie where, you know, it's the 1950s and people are necking in the cars, you know, the old timing cars. You're like necking. You've gone parking is what they called it. Right, right.
Making out. Yeah. And so they had to sweep past all of these cars of people making out until they got to, I think, it was Reese Witherspoon in someone. I can't remember now. But you just got paired up with a person in the background, like pool. You were in the car making out? I was in one of the cars.
But were you faky making out? Yeah, faking making out. You just hug, basically. Exactly. But the thing was, everybody wasn't total strangers because we'd all been hanging out in the background area for like so many weeks. But then it was just kind of funny because they just sort of paired us up with someone. They're like, you're in car A, you're in car B. And the little thing just went past. And I was like, oh my house is so weird. If we watch that scene, we'll like see your ponytail or something? No, I got cut out of it. I don't think I'm in the movie at all. Like I was all over the place. I was in the background of the soda shop. I was in one of the cars. I would walk down the street. I'm nowhere to be found. Hey, anyone out there listening that has seen this movie,
if you think you spotted Jenna, will you do a screen grab and like tag Office Ladies Pod? Incidentally, I had one outfit. So we never changed clothes. So in the soda shop on one day, in the car, walking down the street, I'm always in this yellow outfit with a ponytail. So they gave us one piece of wardrobe,
and we wore it for two weeks in the background. All right, y'all, look for Jenna and her yellow outfit. fit. Okay. Now, question number two is a little bit of a buffet. There's three that they list, and usually you just answer one. I'm going to make you answer all three. Okay. Okay. Do you speak any other languages? I'll put a fronzie. Oh, okay. May we? Do you play a musical instrument? I do not. You tinkered with a guitar for a hot second. Yeah. You made me walk through an airport carrying it. I carried it. I know, but I had to hold it while you. You went to the bathroom.
Yes, I thought I was going to play guitar, but then I broke my back on that trip, and I bruised my elbow. And by the time I was healed, I was over the guitar thing. I wish I played the guitar, and I learned piano growing up, but I quit too early. So no, no musical instruments. It's never too late, lady. It's never too late. I feel like it's too late. Okay, it's too late.
Forget it. It's too late for me. And do you have a favorite book you've read? this is a tough one. This has got to be such a difficult question for you because I feel like there's at least once a month where you leave me a message where you're like, Angela, this book changed by life. I know, I know. I love every book almost that I read. But I'll say my favorite book that I read last year that keeps coming up for me and has actually impacted my life. You were talking about some of the work that I do for the unhoused community, which I have done for all. long time, but was reinvigorated after reading Demon Copperhead.
Yeah. I absolutely loved that book. And within that book, it's, you know, about the struggles of this young man who ends up losing both of his parents and he's put into foster care and he's hungry a lot. And along the way in his life, it got emotional, even just thinking about it, like he's such a real person to me, along the way, there are just every once in a while, someone's kind to him and just creates a human moment with him. That's the thing you shared with me is like giving someone a moment of humanity.
Yeah. And so that became sort of a goal of mine is just there's a lot of unhoused people in Los Angeles. And just the idea that maybe for a brief moment, if they encounter me, I just create that moment of kindness and offer help and support, along with working with some organizations that help with housing and outreach and clothing and things like that. But for me, it's a very personal one-on-one thing. And it's really due to that book of just the moments when in the book, someone would offer him food. And I would just be so happy that someone was kind to him. Yeah. And I felt it so deeply. I thought, oh, my God.
God, I just, I want to be that for somebody if I can. Right. So that book just is a great book. It's a great story. And if I'm making it sound heavy, one of the amazing things about the narrator of the book, who is the boy, is he's funny and he is hopeful. And so it's just a really powerful book and entertaining and easy to read. So I loved it.
And now I am reading another of her books. Barbara Kings Oliver? Yes. Yeah. I am reading the point. Poisonwood Bible, which is also just great so far. I mean, I'm 40 pages in, but very excited. Great. Well, I think that's a fantastic recommendation you guys out there listening. We all need to read it. Yeah, it's great. All right. One of my favorite questions whenever we have a guest,
because I'm just so curious about where people love to go in the world, what's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved. All right, I'm going to divide this into domestically and internationally. Oh, great. Domestically, Oklahoma City, and Chicago. Last year, I got to go to both of those cities for different projects. And you got to really live in both of those cities. Yes. You had an Airbnb and you lived there and you had your market and you met people and your cafes. Yes. I absolutely fell in love with Oklahoma City and the people of Oklahoma city, their crazy wackadoodle weather where it's like an ice storm and then 36 hours later, it's 78 degrees. I was like, what's happening here? And there's like tornado sirens going off.
And also the people locally, they're like, yep, we love it. And I'm like, I get it. I don't know. There's something about it. You're like, and maybe it's because we live in the perpetual sunshine of Los Angeles. But this idea that the weather could be literally. anything tomorrow was very cool and exciting and weird. Exactly. And, you know, my family in North Texas is kind of in that same corridor that Oklahoma City is in. And it brings community together because you're like, yes, a bunch trees are coming down because of this wind. Okay, everybody lets it. And then, you know, all of a sudden there's a heat wave and then it's like pray for rain. And it's like, you know, you just never know. Yes. But also the food. The food was so good.
everywhere I went to eat was so good. There was like this little taco place near our Airbnb that, I mean, we ordered from constantly. And this ramen place that was so good. But all the restaurants, everywhere we ate was great. Lee had to go back recently, and I was so jealous because I wanted to go with him. He had to do a screening of the movie for the crew. New Year's Rev. New Year's Rev. It's coming out this year, although I think the name is changing. Oh, yeah? Yeah. Once it's final, we can talk about it. But yeah, he did a screening for the crew. And I was like, oh, my God, are you going to eat here? Are you going to? He was only there for two days. I was like, where are you going to eat? Because the food was so good. And then, of course, I have gone on and on about Chicago. I just fell in love with that city as well.
Love Chicago. So those are my domestic loves. And then internationally, I loved Copenhagen. Tell me about Copenhagen. I've never been. It is such a charming city. We went as a family. and in the middle of the city, they have an amusement park called Tivoli Gardens, which, Angela, you would love because it's also like a botanical gardens. And you can buy a ticket just to walk around or you can buy a ticket that includes rides. So I bought the walk around ticket. Lee and the kids bought the one for rides. They've got this old roller coaster that is like so old that there's a man that sits in the back and does a break. for when you go around turns.
Oh, my gosh. Isn't that crazy? He's paying attention that day. Oh, my gosh. But there's also like a loop-de-loop, like a more modern roller coaster. It's great. I guess it's supposedly the amusement park that Disneyland was originally based on, and I get it. But it's just super cute.
But we also went to a soccer game there, a football, excuse me. Yeah, a football game. Mm-hmm, which was really cool. And we also rented like a little electric boat and brought a picnic dinner out on the canals and we like putted around the canals. But it was great. It's a great walking city. It was just cool. And again, had great food. If you have good food, I'm going to come to your city. Chita's going to visit. Exactly. So tell her where to eat. She'll be there. Okay. Well, I love those answers. And number four is, what do you like to do on the weekends?
Well, I run a small taxi service for two very demanding clients every weekend. Your clients are, how old? They are 14 and 11. Okay. They have a lot of extracurriculars. So truly, when I say I run a car service, you know, I do the scheduling, which driver, we've got two drivers, me and Lee. Right. So you have two kids with very different interests.
Yes. And you're driving them all over town. It's all I do all weekend. Half the time on the weekend, you and I trade messages. You're like, well, I'm back in the car. Yeah. All over the city. That's basically my weekend.
Every weekend is just shuttling kids to things. But. I'm sorry. I think the question is what do you like to do on the weekends? Not what you actually do on the weekend. Okay. You're right. Okay.
Well, I have been able to carve out sometimes both on Saturday and Sunday, but at least one or the other. I sleep in, which I really like. By sleep in, I mean like 8 a.m. Maybe 8.30, if I'm lucky, that's kind of cool. And then I get my cup of coffee and I go upstairs to my reading nook and I read my book for a long time. If I get to read during the week, maybe it's only for 15 minutes. But on a weekend, I create the space where I get to just sink into my cozy chair and my little nook at the top of my stairs. with my fabulous chairs and my wallpaper.
Your wallpaper. This nook, okay, so you've had that house a long time, but y'all, this nook was like that little kind of square off the top of your stairs. It's like the landing. It's next to the linen cabinet. Yeah, and for years you're like, wait, I don't know what to do with this space. I don't know, I don't know what it is. It's not big enough like to really put too much in it.
And then it just kind of became a catch-all a little bit. And then you made it this cozy nook. And lady, it's brought you so much joy. It's where I read now. And I love it. It's where I did all my prep for the play. I really like it. It's my quiet spot.
So, yeah, that's what I like to do. And I make sure that my weekend, one of the days, sometimes both, includes that. And I'll sit there from like 8.30 to 10 o'clock. Oh, wow. That's amazing. And then I have to start. They have to go to work. Yeah.
You have to go drive your clients around town. Exactly. All right. Last call sheet question. What is your favorite midnight snack? Well, I think it's cereal. If I'm going to have a snack, and I'm interpreting midnight snack as just like 9 p.m. Yeah, exactly.
Like, well, my midnight. Yeah, we're not up that late anymore. Pre-bedtime snack. If I'm going to get hungry and want to eat something, it's going to be cereal. And currently, I'm into frosted mini-weets. Oh, really? I know. It used to be lucky charms, but now frosted mini-weets.
Your cereal always has a little punch of sugar in it. It does. it packs a punch. But when I was younger and I really did eat things at midnight, my two favorites were like a big tub of frozen yogurt or, you know, Ben and Jerry's ice cream. Or for a very long time, I would watch TV and eat easy cheese on top of wheat thins. That's hilarious. Well, lady, all of those answers are so authentically you. and you're really fun to hang out with.
Hey, thanks. Yeah, you're a good hang, as they say. Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, I think we should have an Around the Town and then end with an office question of the week. Let's do it. Right, Sam, we're back. How about some Around the Town action?
Around the Town. Our first message comes from Julia H in Connecticut, who said Julia and Sarah, who have been friends since 2016 when they joined the University of Connecticut marching band as clarinet players, celebrated their 28th birthdays over the weekend. They hosted a, quote, Bob party, where their friends, who are also clarinet players, came dressed as characters who would have Bob haircuts. The party also included pizza and ice cream cake for dessert.
That is hilarious. I have never heard of a Bob party. Julia, I wish you would have told us who all the bob haircut people were. Oh my gosh, I wish we had a picture. Like, my first thing I think of is that scene in Fleabag. Yes, yes. The sister gets the haircut and she's like, I look like a pencil. I thought, and I don't know if this is a bob, but I did think of Merrill Streep's character from the Devil Wears Prada.
Oh. Is that kind of a bob? That's a sassy bob. Maybe. Or isn't the famous Bob right now your friend? Leslie Bibb, her character in... White Lotus. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Okay. Our next around the town is from Ashley B. in Kent, Ohio. Ashley says, hi, Jenna and Angela. The Akron Zoo in Akron, Ohio, through a 25th birthday party for their tawny frogmouth owl. His name is Buzz, and he is one of their animal ambassadors, so he does not have a public exhibit. But you can see the decor, which I think you'll very much enjoy on their social media. hopefully this link will work. Oh my gosh. It's amazing.
It is an owl sitting on his perch and behind him is a banner that says it is your birthday. And then there's all the sad balloons. Partially like deflated balloons. That is hilarious. Yes. I will share that in stories. Oh my gosh. Thank you for sending that, Ashley.
I loved that. And now Alicia W. from Norfolk, Nebraska said, At the parking lot of our local Chipotle, there is one of those little strips of grass and landscaping, and instead of going around this, people would drive straight through the grass. They would just drive right over the median kind of thing.
Yes. Yeah. So, to combat this, the owners decided to place a large boulder amongst the landscaping. Unfortunately, we rural Nebraskaans are such creatures of habit that not one, but several cars have actually driven their same route through the landscaping and gotten their vehicle stuck on the rock. It was such a sensation that some people actually created a Facebook group called
the Rock of Norfolk and named the Rock Ron for Rock of Norfolk. Ron's group has 5.8,000 members, which is 23% of our town's population, and I counted pictures of five or six different vehicles that got stuck on him. After the drama, they finally added a protective circle of poles around Ron, but you can still go visit him. And he has officially been added to Google Maps as a tourist attraction. Well, Alicia, we love this story so much. I actually found a news station that covered it. They're local in Nebraska.
And it's really funny. They show all the pictures of the vehicle. that have been stuck on this rock. And the rock is big. Yeah. There's no way you're going to drive right at it and think I'm going to go over that. It's clearly muscle memory. Yeah.
People are not paying attention. The rock is there. It's big. Anyway, I'm going to put the news broadcast in our stories. Thank you guys all so much for writing in. I love around the towns. All right. Well, now it's time for our office question of the week.
It comes from Phil H. in Spring, Texas, which is right outside of Houston. Phil says the series showed the wedding of Pam and Jim and Dwight and Angela. Was there a reason why the wedding of Michael and Holly was not in an episode of The Office? There is. And it's probably a pretty boring reason. Right. Because, man, that would have made a great episode. I would have loved to see their wedding.
Because, you know, Michael's going to be Bridezilla. You think? Yes. And I think Holly's just going to let him have his moment. But I think Michael's going to have really strong feelings about his. his wedding day. Do you think they would have traded vows like in a Yoda voice? Oh, I think they would have for sure written their own vows, which I would have just loved to hear. Mindy, Mindy Kaling, can we call her and be like, will you write these right now so we can read them on the podcast? Yeah, I think at some point
in the wedding vows, there would have been some type of like accents, character impersonations, things like that. I feel like there would have been maybe some like Princess Bride references. Oh, marriage. Marriage. Wings us together. Yeah. Yeah.
The holy spigot. Yeah. For sure. I don't know. There just would have been a lot of voices. There are you, I will. Yeah, there you go. But it would have been really joyous.
We'll tell you why it didn't happen. It was because, first of all, Steve Correll was no longer under contract with the show, you know. Michael Marries Holly somewhere in season eight or nine. When he shows up for the finale, you know, it's years later. So that wedding happened off camera. But both Amy and Steve had already left the show and were doing other things. And so we just didn't get to see their wedding.
But, man, I so wish that we could have. Yeah. I mean, I think he would have had to make Dwight his best man. You think? Yeah. He wouldn't have tried to make, like, Ryan, his best man or Danny Cordray or one of the last. He would have tried. And, but I think it would have ended up being Dwight.
I do. You do? Yeah, because he would have taken care of Michael and made sure it was all of Michael's favorite things. But there would have been at least one moment where he went too big. And Michael would have been like, damn it, Dwight. I think there might have been a full choir that sings. Mm-hmm. I could see that.
Right. Yeah. Yeah. They would have done the cut the cake thing, and they're both such dorks, the cake theme. What would the cake have been? Oh, that's a good question. Just all the little touches would have been so fun. Yeah, it's too bad.
Oh, you know what I think? Last thing. Because now I'm just so excited, just kind of envisioning the Michael and Holly wedding. I think for sure the two of them would have spent weeks working on a choreographed first dance. Yes. That they would have performed for everyone. Yes. But I also think Michael would have insisted that everybody lift him up on a chair, even though it was not a Jewish wedding.
Yeah, he would have wanted that tradition. The moment. Yes, because he had seen it in a movie or something. Right. Or they would have, like, entered their reception in like a ye oldie carriage or something. I was at a wedding one time where the bride and groom entered in a horse-drawn carriage. They entered the indoors? It was like a Cinderella carriage.
They entered a ballroom. With actual horses. One horse pulling like a little Cinderella round rod iron carriage that they sat in. Do I know these people? No. No. This was a huge Dallas, Texas wedding. Wow.
Yeah. And I literally like the big doors open and then you're like, clip, clop, clop, cleop. I was like, what is happening? Am I an old lady? Because when I hear that I think, oh, what a waste of money. No, you should just, you know what, use that for some good bed linens. Well, you know what, double up on all your sheets. That's a better way to spend your money on it. Get the good towels. Yeah, exactly. That carriage. I'm like, you'll use the towels forever. Yeah. Also, you know, the number of mishaps that can happen getting in and out of that carriage in your dress with your fancy shoes. Yeah. Go get the towels. We're practical ladies. We are.
But also, if you want a carriage at your wedding, you do you. Yes, that's right. I don't judge. I just can't relate. It's different. Stitch that on a pillow. I don't judge. I just can't relate.
It's actually a really great pillow. Well, you guys, this has been really great. Thank you. I feel so celebrated. Angela, when your birthday comes up, we're going to have to do the same thing. You have to answer the call sheet questions now. It was your idea. started it. Okay. Now you have to do it. Oh, great. All right. Sam, Matt, one of your birthdays.
I'm not the only one doing this. And maybe we'll come up with some tribute to you that's like, I'm thinking maybe tennis related. Do we have to share our favorite tennis moment from history? Mine was a surprise to you. Okay. Our shared moment was a surprise. You have to surprise me. Okay. I don't want to know. Okay. But I get to pick my own theme, lady. You don't get to pick my birthday thing. Okay, you pick your theme and then that will point us in a direction. I like it. Okay. Well, thank you, everybody. This was really fun. All right. We'll see you guys next week. We hope you had a great one. Thanks for writing in. We appreciate y'all so much. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. And our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies, we'll be. was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. Lady, have you ever invested in something that seemed really amazing at first,
but then did not live up to the hype? I once got this kind of fancy jacket that looked amazing in the store, but then I wore it out once, and I realized it was not comfortable, and now it just lives in my closet collecting dust. LinkedIn has a word for that, bull spin, Bullspend is when you optimize for numbers that look great, impressions, reach, reactions, but then those numbers don't actually drive revenue. Invest in what actually looks good to your CFO.
LinkedIn ads generate the highest ROAS, 121% of all major ad networks. You can reach the right buyers by targeting company, industry, job title, and more. So cut the bullspend. Advertise on LinkedIn, the network that works for you. Spend $250 on your first campaign on LinkedIn ads and get a $250 credit for the next one. Just go to LinkedIn.com slash office. That's LinkedIn.com slash office.
Terms and conditions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.